The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: You guys have been
talking about graphs in
lecture, right?
So what are graphs?
So graphs are a kind of
formalism that have
vertices and edges.
A set of vertices is-- you
can think of it-- it's
like a set of things.
And then the edges are
the relationships
between those things.
So the set of all your
friendships and your friends'
friendships could be
considered a graph.
So if this is me and this is all
two of my friends, then an
edge between us would indicate
a relationship of friendship.
But there's no edge here,
so there's no friendship
between these two.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So you have vertices, which
are also called nodes, and
then you have edges, and they
could also be called arcs.
So if you see any of these
names, these two are the same,
and these two are the same.
So what kinds of graphs
do we have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So there's a directed
graph, and there's an
undirected graph.
So up on the screen here, is
a directed graph, right?
And so--
I'm not a sports fan.
I think those are the Bruins,
and I don't know what the
other team is.
Do you know?
OK.
Yes, I think it's a hockey team
somewhere up in Montreal.
So this is a representation or
a graph representation of
cities, which are the nodes
and vertices and then the
roads that connect the cities.
And, obviously, it's not to
scale or accurate, but it's an
abstraction, so we're
OK with that.
And the question here is what's
the path to get from
Boston to Montreal.
So in this case, it's a directed
graph, so that means
that we can only go this
direction from node to node,
in the direction of the arrow.
So, really, there's only
one way to go, right?--
two hops.
So that's a directed graph, and
then an undirected graph
is basically the same thing,
except we can go either
direction on the edges, right?
So on the directed graph in the
previous slide, you could
only go in this direction, so
you had to make two hops in
order to get to Montreal.
In this undirected graph, you
can just make one hop to get
to Montreal-- so really
conceptually very easy.
AUDIENCE: Can you have a
directed graph in a case where
there's one going from Boston
to New York and another one
going from New York to Boston?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So--
and actually we'll see
that in the code.
So the question was, can I have
New York here and then
Boston here?
Can I have this sort
of relationship?
And the answer is yes.
This is actually just
equivalent to
an undirected graph.
AUDIENCE: Probably you can have
a directed graph in some
cases like that.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So you could have--
and we actually have-- actually,
I think this might
have an example of
that, so, yes.
So in this case, you have--
Hartford has a path to Albany
and back in a path to New York
City, but there's no path
directly back to Hartford.
That work for you?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
PROFESSOR: Well, then I won't
insult Hartford then.
I didn't do these graphs.
If I had done them, I certainly
wouldn't have used
sports teams because I know next
to nothing about sports.
So I don't know the rationale
behind picking the names,
other than I'm supposed to say
that the reason why the Bruins
want to go to Montreal is
because they want to kick
Canada's butt.
AUDIENCE: They did.
PROFESSOR: Did they?
AUDIENCE: They already have.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Well, then this is a very
apropos slide then.
So what we have up here is
a weighted graph, right?
So the undirected and directed
graphs have been really easy
so far because they're just
defining the fact that there
is a relationship that exists
between two vertices, right?
So what a weighted graph does,
though, is it says that not
only is there a relationship
between these two entities--
these vertices--
but it also has maybe a cost
associated with it.
So if these represent the road
networks, then these
represent, kind of,
the total costs--
the weights on these edges.
So in saying that in order to
get the Hartford, I need to
pay $1.00; and then to get to
Albany, I need to pay $3.00;
and then to get to Montreal,
to pay $6.00.
So a common question--
on weighted graphs in general--
is what's the least
cost path from here to here.
So can anyone tell me?
AUDIENCE: From Boston
to Montreal?
PROFESSOR: Yes--
what the least cost is from
Boston to Montreal.
AUDIENCE: It's--
Hartford is your only choice.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Then New York
and then Hartford.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So-- and the cost for that is
$9.00, right?-- because you
got $1.00, $7.00, $1.00--
sum $9.00.
There are actually
two paths to get
from Boston to Montreal.
The other path is from Boston,
Hartford, Albany, Montreal,
but the cost of that
path is $10.00.
So the question is how do you
figure out which path is
shortest, right?
So did he talk about
breadth-first search and
depth-first search at all?
AUDIENCE: He only talked
about depth-first.
PROFESSOR: He only talked
OK.
So we need to do
breadth-first.
So before we do breadth-first,
can someone define depth-first
for me and maybe walk me through
it a little bit?
So let's take this off the
screen, and let's assume that
I have a very simple graph.
I'm going to start here.
I want to end here.
And I have--
So I'm starting at v0, and
I want to get to v8.
Let's call this a directed
graph, so you
can only go one direction.
It also doesn't have any cycles,
so that makes it a
little easier.
So if I'm starting here
in depth-first
search, what do I do?
AUDIENCE: Pick a daughter--
Pick a daughter?
PROFESSOR: So you pick one of
your children, so you're going
to pick v1 or v4.
Now, you go to this node.
What do you do now?
AUDIENCE: Pick a daughter.
PROFESSOR: Same thing again.
So you pick another daughter and
because this is a really
trivial example, we just walk
down the line until you find
the node that you're
looking for.
Or if you don't find it,
and you have no more--
there are no more children to
look at, then there's no path
that exists.
But we can get to our goal
node here, right?
So what do we do once
we find this node?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We save
it off somewhere.
It becomes a path with just
itself, and then we return
that to who--
And then we say, OK, well,
where did I come from?
Well, I came from v7.
So, now, I know that my shortest
path from v7 to v8 is
going to be v7-v8.
And then I'm back here,
I'm going to add
wherever I came from here.
So the idea is that I grow my
shortest paths backwards.
Right?
And, actually, the shortest path
is the top one here, so--
AUDIENCE: If you hit a branch
in v7, can you go back to v7
would you jump to
the next branch?
PROFESSOR: So, yes.
So if I had something
like this, and the
answer would be--
let's say that it
loops around--
so now we have a cycle.
So it becomes interesting.
So let's say that I've reached
my goal here, and I know that
if I'm at my goal, then
my shortest path is
just my goal, right?
So now I return here and I say,
well, what would be my
shortest path in this case?
Does this child have
the shortest path?
When I get here first to v7, I
asked the question, what's the
shortest path to v8 from either
of my two children.
So I'm going to look at all the
children of v7, and I'm
going to find what's the
shortest path from v8--
or from this node to
the end node--
and then from this node
to the end node.
And, obviously, this one's
the shortest because
it is the end node.
So now, I know that
my shortest path
is this plus myself.
And so that means that the
shortest path from v6 to the
end node is going to be
this path, plus this.
And I don't know if that's
getting any clearer.
So, really, if we start out at
the beginning here, we're
looking at this first node--
we ask the question, what's the
shortest path from v1 to
the end, and what's
the shortest path
from v4 to the end?
And we choose the shortest of
those two paths as our answer,
then we just add ourselves
to the beginning.
And that's all we do for
each of these nodes.
We ask, of the children at each
of these nodes, what's
the shortest path, and then we
add ourselves to the beginning
of that path and return
that as our answer.
So if we are to look
at that in code--
so you guys have all seen the
graph object in class with the
node and edges?
Yes or no?
OK So here is shortest
path depth-first.
So there's a lot of debugging
code here, but--
and some administrative stuff--
so all this is doing
is just making sure that
the nodes we're looking
for are in the graph.
And, actually, let
me backtrack.
So when we first call shortest
path, we're going to call it
with a graph object.
We're going to start
in an end node.
And we're also going to have
this parameter visited, which
keeps track of the nodes that
we've already seen.
And we'll get to that
in a second.
So one of the first things
that we do that's of any
importance is, we check to make
sure that the start and
end nodes are actually in the
graph, because you can't get
from one to the other
if they don't exist.
And now we're going to construct
a path or a list
that just contains the start
node as its element.
And then we're going
to check to see if
start is equal to end.
So if we're already at our goal,
then the shortest path
is just us, right?
We don't have to go anywhere.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: For comparison
purposes.
I mean, if you look at the
definition of node, it's
pretty sparse--
pretty spartan.
If we wanted to make it so that
we just added the node
object itself, would have to add
an underbar equal method--
stuff like that-- and in this
case, we don't want to bother
with kind of complicating
it like that.
So if we're not at the end,
though, now, we need to figure
out what the shortest path is
from each of our children to
the goal node, right?
So we have a variable that we
call shortest, and that's
going to keep track of what our
shortest path so far is,
and then we're going to iterate
through all the
children in this node.
And if the node is
not in visited--
and that's where this
parameter comes in--
we're going to say, OK, well,
let's take a look at it.
And then we're going to say--
we're going to add it to
visited so we know that
we visited this node.
It sounds kind of cyclic, which
is funny because we have
visited so that we
avoid cycles.
Because if we've already visited
a node and we figured
out what its shortest path
is, why would we
want to visit it again?
If we're on a path,
and we're saying--
let's say I have--
I'm trying to figure out the
shortest path from v1 to v4--
and I'm using depth-first--
and so I decide depth-first
first goes to v2, then to v3.
Now, it's got two choices on
which nodes to get the
shortest path for.
Let's say, for some reason,
when it gets the list of
children, it's going to get v1
and v4, and if it's looking at
v1 before it looks at v4, then,
if we didn't have that
check in there, just
to make sure
that we are not visiting--
or looking at other nodes that
we've already visited--
then the algorithm would just
go here, and it would repeat
itself in a cycle, like that.
So that's what that visited
parameter is doing, is it's
preventing that cyclic check.
So now we ask the question--
or we make a recursive call
to shortest path, right?
And the only parameter that
changes is the start node.
And we're going to ask it,
what's the shortest path from
this node to the end.
And it's going to call itself
again and return an answer.
And if it doesn't return
anything, then we're just
going to ignore it
and continue.
But if it returns something,
and either we haven't found
shortest path yet, or the length
of this new path that
it's found is shorter than the
shortest path that we've
already found, then we're going
to record it, and say
that this is our new
shortest path here.
And then we're just going to
keep iterating through all the
children of the node until
we've exhausted all
possibilities.
And then once we finish going
through all the children,
we're going to say--
if we found the shortest
path--
that means that there exists a
path from one of its children
to the goal node--
then we're going to add it to
our existing path, which is
just ourself.
So we're adding ourselves to the
beginning of the shortest
path that it found.
And then we will return it.
So it's kind of growing the
shortest path from the back to
the front, right?
Breadth-first search works in
the opposite direction.
So the way that--
well, first, is anyone confused
by depth-first search?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So this line here--
this is--
well, this if statement
first is checking to
see that we've got--
that one of our children
has a shortest path.
It's possible that none of our
possible children leads to the
goal node, so let's say that
I have another kind
of subgraph on here.
When v2 is my start node,
I'm still going to
check these two children.
And let's say that my goal node
is to get to v8, right?
Well, I'm still going to check
to see what the shortest path
is for both of these children.
Well, once I use this is my
start node, there's obviously
no path to the actual goal
node, so the depth-first
search call, or the call to the
shortest path, is going to
return none in this case.
And we need to check that, so
that's what that bit of code
is doing there.
It's saying if there is a
shortest path, then we're
going to just add ourselves to
the front of that shortest
path, and return that
as our answer.
But if there is no
shortest path
from one of our children--
from any of the children
on the start node--
to the goal node, then we're
just going to return none as
our answer because we can't
get to the goal node from
where we are.
Did that work for you?
So why don't we take a look
at how this is working.
So we're going to try DFS
on undirected graph.
And the code that does this is
called Test 2 here, and all it
does is, it creates a
graph with 10 nodes.
And, in this case, it's going
to be an undirected graph.
And we're going to create
a bunch of edges.
So--
is that diagram you sent
out, is that the
representation of it?
AUDIENCE: This is the code
from lecture, Professor
[INAUDIBLE] code.
So it only uses 5 nodes.
PROFESSOR: So we have this
graph, and what we're going to
do is use depth-first search to
compute the shortest path
from here to here.
So this is showing the depth
of the recursion, right?
So we start off on node 0, and
then it starts looking for the
shortest path from 1 to 4.
And at the same depth, it's
going to try and find the
shortest path from 2 to 4.
So it starts out here, and
then it asks what's the
shortest path from 1 to 4, and
then what's the shortest path
from 2 to 4.
And so when it's looking at 1,
now it's going to ask what's
the shortest path from--
I want it to do that--
Hey, Sarri?
Is there a bug in your code?
AUDIENCE: Is there?
PROFESSOR: So is this
the lecture code?
AUDIENCE: None of
this is mine.
I did the breadth-first
search.
This is the depth-first?
PROFESSOR: Yes, because
it seems like it's
checking node 0 twice.
AUDIENCE: It didn't
do that on mine.
PROFESSOR: So it's
going from--
AUDIENCE: Oh, no-- because
there's a directed-- is from 1
to 0, right?
Yes.
So what it's doing-- what the
code does is, it says--
it does a depth-first, so first,
it looks at node 0, and
then it goes for child in--
for all the children nodes.
What's the first child
of node 0?
It's node 1.
PROFESSOR: Oh, because 0 hasn't
been added to the
visited list.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And then--
PROFESSOR: And then it asks,
what are all the children of--
AUDIENCE: Well, no.
The print statement comes
before it discovers that
checking node 0 is
an invalid path.
I forgot to add another
print statement.
If you go to the code--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So where are we at?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So see how I have the
very first at
the top of the function?
See how there's the
if to print?
I say that, but then there's
this check here
if it's not in visited.
If it is in visited, there's no
print statement that says--
PROFESSOR: --that says that--
you know-- it's--
AUDIENCE: That-- yes.
So, basically, what's happened
is, when we do that second
check where we end up finding
the second path from 0 to 4,
it ends up hitting that test
that says, we've already
visited node 0, so we
don't continue that.
PROFESSOR: I got it.
I got it.
That was just a little--
AUDIENCE: There was no print
statements in the code before,
and I was having a really hard
time figuring it out, and I
did this, and this made
it a lot more clear--
I thought-- to try and figure
out how the depth-first search
was working.
PROFESSOR: No, I
think so, too.
It's just maybe we should
add a couple extra--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I agree.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
I was perplexed-- because
I'm like, uh-oh.
So it's working correctly.
Is there any confusion
on depth-first
search, in spite of that?
OK.
So let's start our breadth-first
search.
So you guys covered depth-first
search in lecture,
so we need to do breadth-first
search.
OK.
So the idea behind breadth-first
search is that
instead of asking the question,
what's the shortest
path from v1 to v4 and adding
ourselves to the front of
that, to get the shortest path,
we're going to build the
paths from the start outward--
or from the start forward--
so, in this case, we're building
the paths from the
goal backward.
In this case, we're going to
say, I'm at v0, so my current
partial path is v0.
Then I'm going to look
at v1 and v4.
And so I'm going to have--
I'm going to say, now, this
is my list of partial
paths to the goal.
And then, for v1, I'm
going to say--
I'm going to ask what its
neighbors are, and we have v2.
And then, for v4, we're going
to ask the same question.
So now we're building
our partial paths.
So, conceptually, what we're
doing is, we're just
maintaining a list of all
the paths that we--
or all-- the history
of nodes--
or paths that we've been looking
at and just kind of
going out one by one by one.
So if we look at this in
code, shortest path--
BFS--
has a slightly different call
signature than the DFS method.
So we still get a graph, and
then we get this variable
called paths.
And what paths contains is the
partial path, or list of the
partial paths of tuples.
So the format of this is, each
element has a list of the
nodes in the path and
then the length of
that particular path.
So we also have the goal node.
And what we do--
the first thing that happens is,
this pass gets shorted--
or sorted.
So it's sorted by the
length of the path.
So is anyone puzzled by
this lambda here?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So when you call the sorted
function, you
can pass it a list.
You can also pass it
this key parameter.
And this key parameter is a
function that takes an object,
and it'll return, kind
of, the value
associated with that object.
So, in this case, each of
these paths contain--
each of the elements and
paths contains a tuple.
And what this key function does
is, it says, each element
in this path has got a value
that is equal to the
length of that path.
And this length parameter--
that's just the second element
in the tuple, right?
So when sorted does its work,
it's going to call this key
function on each element
in path.
And what this function has
to do is return the value
associated with that
particular element.
AUDIENCE: Is lambda just a key
word that generates an effect?
PROFESSOR: Lambda is
what's known as
an anonymous function.
And he covered that in a
lecture at one point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Did he
just use lambda?
AUDIENCE: He blew
past it, so--
this is something
called lambda.
Ask your TAs.
PROFESSOR: Well, since I'm
your TA and I'm here--
so real briefly--
lambda is a way of, kind of,
doing really simple--
not really simple functions--
but it's a way of creating
anonymous function.
So let's say that I want
to create a function
that squares a number.
This is exactly--
well, not exactly-- but, it's
equivalent to this.
I can use g as a function just
as easily as I can use h.
That's all.
And it's useful for situations
where you have elements that
don't have an order to find.
So like, sorted needs to know a
value of an element in order
to put it in order-- in order
to do the sorting, right?
So that's what this function
does, is it gives each element
in that list a value so that
the sorting can do its job.
So the key that we want to sort
on, or the item that we
want to sort on, is the
length the path.
And the reason why we want to
do that is, we're going to
take the first partial path that
exists in our paths, and
for every node in
the shortest--
or for every node in the--
for every child of the last node
in this path, we want to
check to see if it's the goal,
and if it's not, then we're
going to append a new partial
path, which is the path that
we're looking at, plus one
of the children nodes.
And then the length of
the path to this
value called new paths.
So it's saying--
this node that I'm
looking at--
let's say that this is
my partial path.
What it's doing is, it's looking
at this last node in
this path, and it's saying
what are all the
children of this node?
And if none of the children are
the goal node, then it's
going to create a new set of
paths that are composed of
this path, plus all
the children.
AUDIENCE: So if v2 also went to
v10, would the new path be
easier [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
So we should probably
get rid of this.
The reason why breadth-first
search has its name, is that
it doesn't try to go towards
the end immediately.
It grows gradually.
So if you can kind of envision
a graph like this.
Depth-first works by going--
by proceeding down until it
finds the goal node for each
of the possible paths.
Right?
What breadth-first search does
is, it starts at a node, and
then it builds all the
paths from that node.
And then for each of these,
it builds the paths.
So that's what I'm saying when
I say partial paths.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's a new partial path, so--
AUDIENCE: So it would be v0,
v1, v2, v4-- the next one.
And v0, v2, v [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So let's say
this is v0, v1, v2.
Let's say that I have this
partial path already.
All right?
When I build a new partial--
when I'm looking at this path,
which is what I'm doing when I
pop it off the front of
the list of paths
that I already have--
I'm going to look at
all its children.
So I'm going to look at these
two nodes right here.
And then I'm going to say--
let's say that my goal node is
here, and then I'm going
to say that these
aren't my goal nodes.
So I'm going to create new
partial paths, and one of them
is going to be v0,
v1, v2, and v4.
So I already have that.
And the other partial
path is going to be
v0, v1, v2, and v5.
AUDIENCE: You just find every
single possible path to get
the tuples [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Until you reach
the goal node.
So with depth-first search,
you do have to--
well, no, not even with
depth-first search.
There's some interesting
properties about the different
searches, but we just want you
to be familiar with how they
go about doing their task.
So the idea is that we start
off with a partial path--
just this guy--
and then we find all the
other partial paths.
So it'll start off with
just this guy
as its list of paths--
so one element--
and then it's going to pop
this off the front.
It's going to say, OK, I'm
looking at this partial path.
What are the additional paths
that I can build off of this?
And I can build four additional
paths off of this.
So now I have a set of four
paths that I want to look at.
And then it takes a look at,
say, this partial path of v0,
v1, and it says, what are the
paths that I can build off of
this, and then adds
it to the end.
And then it says, what are
the paths that I can
build off of this guy--
adds those to the end-- what are
the paths that I get from
this guy-- adds those to the
end, and so on and so forth.
AUDIENCE: So you keep track
of all the paths that you
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Oh, OK.
Is that what you meant?
AUDIENCE: You hit a node-- and
there's another possible
thing-- but if you don't hit a
node-- if there's some paths
somewhere else in the graph,
then it doesn't
ever reach into that.
It just doesn't account
for it.
PROFESSOR: Well, I mean, it is
possible for breadth-first
search to go find nodes that
don't reach the goal, but
what's going to happen
in those cases is,
they're going to--
so let's say that there's such
a path at the front of this
paths list, and it doesn't
have any children.
So you can't go anywhere after
you've gotten to this node.
Then what's going to happen is
this for loop's not going to
execute, right?-- because
it has no children.
And so it's just going to be
discarded as a possibility.
So I mean, the key thing is that
you're generating these
new partial paths for every node
that you're looking at.
And you're adding those to a
list or a queue of partial
paths that you need to examine
in the future if you don't
find your goal.
If you do find a partial path
that has a child that is the
goal, then you can just
immediately return that path
because you know it's going
to be the shortest
path, in this case.
So--
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: So what happens when
you find two partial paths
that both reach?
PROFESSOR: Well, then it depends
on which one appears
first in your list.
So you're asking--
let's do something
really simple--
if I have--
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
So that makes sense.
PROFESSOR: So at some point,
you're going to have a partial
path right here, or a list of
partial paths that consist of
v0, v1, and then v0 and v2.
Whichever path you ultimately
wind up returning is going to
be dependent on whether or not
this one comes first in your
list of partial paths to check,
or this one comes first
in your list of partial
paths to check.
Did that kind of answer it?
So is everyone good on
breadth-first search,
conceptually?
Is the code flummoxing anyone?
AUDIENCE: How do you find which
one is the shortest?
PROFESSOR: If you're building
your partial path--
so you've popped off this path
that you're examining--
and you look at all its
children, and one of the
children is a goal node, then
you know that you've found the
shortest path, right?--
because you've been building
this incrementally,
one by one by one.
And then if you've found the
goal node, then you know to--
you know, you already built up
the shortest path possible.
Because if the goal node had
been on a shorter path before,
you would have found
it already.
AUDIENCE: That would be a
different scenario if that
path were weighted.
PROFESSOR: Well, if the paths
are weighted, then it's a
little different because
here, we're just
doing shortest path.
What you're talking about is
doing a least cost path, in
which case the main difference
would be how it sorts its list
of candidate paths, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: When it does sort it,
it would say, keep this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] path
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So in this case, our lambda
function is saying that we're
going to sort these lists
based on their length.
But if I wanted to say, sort
them based on the sum of their
weights, then I would have a
function that sums up the
weights on that path and uses
that in the sorting in order
to select the next partial
path to search.
AUDIENCE: Although, in that
case, you'd actually have to
ennumerate every single possible
path, to show you
found the lowest cost path.
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: Because doesn't--
I might understand this-- is
that you find all the paths of
length one through a certain
point and all the
paths of length 2.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And so if you're
worried about cost, it's
possible-- in principal-- that
your longest path is your
lowest cost path.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
You're not sorting it
by length then.
PROFESSOR: Right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: But what he's saying
is that because you're
growing it by one each time,
then it's possible that--
let's say that I have partial
paths of length 2, but my
least cost path is actually of
length 5, then even if one of
these nodes reaches--
like, say that v2 reaches the
goal before the actual least
cost path, then you
can't stop.
You do have to integrate
through all of them.
AUDIENCE: Well, you just
sort it by cost.
I think that it's a better
example to say that if you
have one partial path
that has cost 7 ...
PROFESSOR: Well,
actually, wait.
No.
You're actually right.
Because if you sort it by cost,
then your least cost
path is going to be in front
of your queue all the time.
AUDIENCE: No, I don't
think that's true.
Because imagine this--
imagine you had a graph
that was like-- this
is your start node.
This is your end node,
and you go like
this, this, this, this.
And so you make a breadth-first,
where you go to
this node and this node, and the
cost of this is 1 and the
cost of this is 8.
The cost of this is 20 and
the cost of this is 1.
This is your shortest path, or
this is your cheapest path,
but when you add them-- they're
both of length 1--
so you explore this one first
because it's the cheapest at a
cost of 1, but the total
cost is 21 to
continue from this node.
But the total cost is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] that node.
So I think that he's right.
Right?
I thought you had to expand all
nodes when you're doing
breadth-first.
That's why you do, like,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But, yes.
For weights you have to
expand all of them.
PROFESSOR: So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes?
PROFESSOR: Possibly, yes.
I'm blanking on the answer.
But in this case, we don't have
to enumerate all paths.
AUDIENCE: We're just looking for
the shortest path-- we can
just find the shortest path.
PROFESSOR: Right.
But if you're incorporating
costs, then you would use a
different algorithm, so it'd be,
like, actual shortest path
algorithm or something
like that.
So why don't we just run this.
AUDIENCE: So is one better
than the other, when you
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: They have different
running characteristics.
It really depends on
your application.
The nice thing about depth-first
search is that
it's fairly memory efficient
because with breadth-first
search, you're storing all
the possible paths--
all the possible
partial paths.
With depth-first search, you
only have one path and memory
at a given point, right?
You have the path that you've
already found from one of your
children to the end
node, plus 1.
But with the breadth-first
search, you're going to have a
list of all the partial
paths that you
have to search through.
So let's see.
This doesn't make sense.
AUDIENCE: I don't think it
matches the picture.
AUDIENCE: [0, 4] is
a path, isn't it?
From the graph?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yes.
No, it's not matching
the picture.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
PROFESSOR: Is what?
AUDIENCE: It was undirected.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it was an
undirected graph-- that's why.
So if we run it directed,
let's see what happens.
AUDIENCE: 0 to 4 is still
in the graph.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
You are absolutely right.
Oh, you know what's going
on-- it's running both.
It's running the depth-first
search.
AUDIENCE: No, it's running
both the directed and the
undirected.
PROFESSOR: Well, it's
also running the
depth-first search as well.
That was my question, because
I was looking at this, and I
was, like, that's not
breadth-first search, that's
depth-first search.
This, on the other hand, is
breadth-first search.
So there we go.
So if we have a graph--
and let's see--
so it starts off with node 0,
and then it builds a new list
of partial paths with [0, 1],
[0, 2], so it's got, in this
case, this partial path and
then this partial path.
And then it expands
one of them.
So, in this case,
I guess [0, 1]
was the path that was first
on the list, right?
So it's going to expand the
children of 1, which is just 2
and itself.
But it's going to
avoid cycles.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
And then it's going to expand
this partial path-- the [0, 2]
--
because it's the shortest one,
and it's going to add that new
partial path to the end.
And then it's going to expand
this guy, and add the
expansion here, and then it's
going to expand this guy.
And it turns out that one of
the children of 3 is 4.
So it's found the shortest
path from 0 to 4.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: So, can you go
back to [INAUDIBLE]?
Then why does it say
[0, 2, 3] then?
PROFESSOR: That's the
representation in the pass
list, so each element in
the path's list is
represented as a tuple.
The first element is the list
of nodes on that path, and
then the second element is
the length of that path.
And that's why we had that
lambda function in the first
place, right?
So if you read the specification
here, you have
path length, and then
you have the nodes
that are on that path.
And when we sort the path list--
because we need to make
sure that we're looking
at the shortest path--
then we use this lambda function
in order to get that
length for each tuple.